just bring you some breaking news a
teenager has been found guilty of
killing two sisters in north
london last year daniel hussain
stabbed buba henry and nicole smallman
in a park
in wembley we have more information on
this case now here's our home affairs
correspondent
mark white armed with taser stun guns
this is the moment police move in to
arrest killer daniel hussain
you're under arrest keep walking towards
me stay where you are hands on your head
stay where you
are he looks remarkably unfazed but just
weeks earlier
this teenager had murdered two sisters
in a frenzied knife attack part of a
bizarre deal with the devil
this is one of the last images of
hussein's victims
biba henry and nicole smallman a selfie
taken by them
minutes before they were murdered the
sisters had been among a group of
friends
on the 5th of june last year celebrating
bieber's birthday
and the partial lifting of the first
coved lockdown
they'd chosen the sprawling frying
country park
in northwest london to let their hair
down
as their friends drifted off home nicole
and biba stayed on
late into the night dancing with fairy
lights
as darkness descended oblivious to the
fact their killer
was also in the park looking for victims
everything you find out about nicole and
bieber a wonderful family
great friends you know these two are the
life and soul of everything you know
they loved
life they loved each other deeply they
loved their families
and to have their lives ended in such a
dramatic and terrible ways does really
doesn't really bear thinking about
in police custody hussein still had
injuries to his right hand
deep cuts he sustained while stabbing
biba and nicole
yeah yeah just did the wrists from the
cuffs no no
no detectives pieced together his
movements on the night of the murders
this is him arriving back at his
father's house near the park
his blood-stained trousers removed the
injured hand
tucked into the jacket tied around his
waist
the blood from that injury was found all
around the crime scene
this is him in a supermarket in the days
before the murders
buying the block of knives he'd go on to
use in the attack
and in a search of his mother's home
police uncovered a far
more sinister aspect to this crime
satanic symbols in his bedroom
and nearby a handwritten letter it was
a pact with the devil a promise to kill
six women every six months it was signed
in his own blood
in return he believed he'd win the
lottery
and have better luck with women
search teams even found receipts for
lottery tickets
purchased in the days after the murders
it's not known why the sisters were
targeted this is biba
and nicole in a local co-op buying food
and drink
shortly before heading to fryent park
tragically they may simply have been in
the wrong place
at the wrong time when hussein
discovered them
as horrific as this crime undoubtedly is
for the family and friends of the
sisters
there was the added trauma of being told
that two police officers
sent to guard the murder scene had
subsequently been charged
with taking unauthorized pictures of the
sisters
those two officers are due to appear at
the old bailly later this month
and now daniel hussein who lied
repeatedly to police
claiming he wasn't a killer but a victim
of a robbery attack himself
stands convicted of murder of killing
two sisters
who'd simply been relishing life and
celebrating their freedom from lockdown
mark white sky news